>>I was born in Suva, which
is the capital of Fiji
and life was different in
almost every single way.
My father felt that if I received a
college education here I would be a
lot more successful, so that was one
of the significant
reasons we left Fiji.
I started eighth grade here
and I struggled academically
at first. Coming here to Impact
was really the key thing
that helped me change, because I
was given a chance to start over.
>>My name is Rahil Maharaj and
I go to Impact Academy of Arts
and Technology in Hayward, which is a
small project-based learning school.
We focus on a couple of really
important leadership skills,
like collaborate productively,
critical thinking,
communicate powerfully, and
complete projects effectively.
So along with making sure
that students are keeping
up with the content, they're
also getting these life skills
that they'll need to be successful
in college and in the workplace.
>>An assignment that I had for my
AP government class was the paper
on federalism.
This paper focused
on the Constitution
and analyzing the Constitution
to determine whether the state
or the federal government should
be in charge of a specific issue.
>>All the students were given
the choice to pick any issue
and I picked immigration.
The states recently
have been passing laws
and the federal government has
been deeming them unconstitutional.
>>My family immigrated here so it
kind of pertained to me as well.
And it really evoked
something in me to research
and see what the actual
solution to that issue would be.
After researching all
the current affairs
about immigration I began looking
for laws that would give powers
to Congress or give
powers to the states.
Immigration is not specifically
mentioned in the Constitution,
so you have to analyze more
generalized law and apply it.
I came to the conclusion that
the federal government should be
in charge, because not only
is Congress responsible
for national security, the rights
should be consistent throughout every
state, because we do as a
nation believe in equality.
>>I think deeper learning is
when a student learns
something beyond the content
that we're supposed to, where
they're able apply their experiences
or apply the knowledge
that they receive
from other classes into
what they're doing.
Learning something through deeper
learning really means internalizing
the information.
>>Before coming to Impact I
wasn't really sure whether
or not I had the right skills and
grades to be able to go to college.
Impact gave me the inspiration
that I was going to have the skills
to be successful in college.
It is really important
for me to go to college
because it will give me the skills
and knowledge that I need to succeed,
which is the key reason
that my parents came here,
to ensure that my brothers and I have
a successful career and a happy life.